I know most of you know that Donald Trump
lies, but here's a hilarious story.
Trump often has stories about his black friend
or his veteran friend, that type of thing
where he says, Oh yeah, no, my, my black friend
told me this, or my veteran friend told me
that normal people would see how much Trump
lies and immediately suspect that those stories
are also lies.
Trump has been selling, telling or selling
it, I guess we can say both ways.
He's been telling a similar story about his
Jewish friend and every time the Jewish friend
is somebody else.
This is just the best.
Trump told basically the same story on September
9th December 7th and twice on December 11th
at different events.
The context is always that Trump says he did
the right thing by getting out of the Iran
deal and he supports this by saying, even
my Jewish friend came to me and said, the
best thing wasn't, you know, moving the embassy
or whatever the best thing was getting out
of that Iran deal.
The first time he mentioned that it was people
who were telling him this.
The second time Trump told the story verbatim.
He said it was big Republican donor, Sheldon
Adelson who told them this.
Then the third time he told a story, it was
the owner of the new England Patriots, NFL
football team, Bob Kraft, who told him this.
And then the fourth time that he was praised
for getting out of the Iran deal, it was the
father of his son in law, Jared Kushner, Charles
Cushner, check out this compilation video
with Trump telling the same story four times
each time.
Naming somebody else
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I said to Sheldon,
what do you think was bigger?
Israel and the embassy going in and it became
Jerusalem, the capital of Israel or the Golan
Heights.
He said neither.
He said, the biggest thing you did for Israel
was breaking up and terminating.
It's a horrible, one-sided,
catastrophic deal that was made by president
Obama.
I said, Bob craft, which is bigger, which
is more important to the Jewish people.
They said neither.
I said, what does that mean?
He said, what you did by terminating the Iran
nuclear deal
is bigger than both.
I think that's true,
and then I asked Charlie Cushner, I said,
Charlie, let me ask you, what's bigger for
the Jewish people giving the embassy to Jerusalem?
It becomes the capital of Israel.
What's bigger that or the Golan Heights?
He said, neither.
I said, what does that mean?
He said, the biggest thing of all is what
you did by ending the Iran nuclear deal.
Yes.
I think that's true.
Apparently Trump has asked this question many
times and all of his Jewish friends seem to
be giving him the same answer, right?
He's having trouble keeping the lies straight.
That's what's going on.
We recently did a segment about compulsive
lying and here we are with a great example.
Trump lies so much.
It's so second nature to him to make stuff
up that he can't keep the lies straight.
Or he has those delusions where he thinks
nobody will notice and he just tells the story
differently each time.
For kicks, much like many of the compulsive
liars that I've known in my life, and of course
if you call them out, if you, and December
11th after Trump did the first event and said,
Hey, Kraft said this to me, and in the second
event it was Charlie Cushner who said this
to him.
If you said, you know, you just told the same
story and name two different people, he would
come up with something.
He would say, well, it was actually both of
them who said it to me.
Or he would say, well, they both basically
said the same thing or, well, Cushner said
it before and Kraft said it more recently
and both stories are true.
I just told them out of order.
I get a lot of emails that say, David, this
is very clear evidence of dementia.
And I've said before, Trump may have cognitive
decline, but Trump clearly remembers enough
that he could tell this story one way every
time.
If it was a real story, actual possible cognitive
decline aside, we're letting them off the
hook when we say this is merely dementia.
This is merely cognitive decline.
This is a liar who lies so much that he probably
is not remembering which lies he's told who
he's told them to.
And this is what you end up with.
As a final result, even the American right
should be scared to death that this guy has
control over nuclear weapons.
He has a huge degree of control over the financial
future of the United States.
This is very scary stuff because he's lying
about insignificant things as we know, crowd
size, hand size, I think you know what I mean.
Um, uh, these Jewish friends who tell him
this stuff, but he's also lying about really,
really big things as well.
And we've reported on many of them.
This is scary stuff.
This is the stuff of nightmares.
And now let's actually step back a little
bit and quantify the dishonesty and frame
it historically in terms of what we're now
experiencing.